did you ever move back to kelly
well let's see what this guy has to say
sorry brandon the bike the podcast is up
it's just gonna be some sting brandon
oh it's been staying for a couple weeks
over there
you and chris you better eat some weird
[ __ ]
what's on the menu what's on the menu
next
oh they're probably getting freaking
ridiculous over there
dude i think i'm flying in
through a delicacy
get out of here get the volume on riley
no hold on so you're not going back bro
you're not going i'm going back dude
[ __ ] you bro this is a question turn the
question on right i can't even throw my
mic because there's no sun coming out
either even i don't fix the damn deal i
couldn't even throw my mic away because
y'all made fun of me for the way i laugh
on the podcast who did
you shut the [ __ ] up
that is you oh yeah that's you
who said that who did that one i did
that's awesome bro
find a better way to fix it riley yeah i
know that's what i'm trying to do okay
i was crying sorry man this question was
probably all
these kids you got working here bro like
12 years old
it's getting bad you got a little peter
pan factory going on
what's going on that's the one thing you
find out outside of l.a in new york dude
it's young boy
how would you doesn't even know what the
[ __ ] pythagorean theorem is
this kid's nine years old the god
[ __ ] wrote it
he's hate not greed whatever
riley mao how old are you i'm 22. there
you go
hairless too this is our last episode
here man where's the new one
well i don't know i'm not telling you
i'm not telling brendan i'm not telling
you
i tell the police because there's 15
more of his [ __ ] cousins in there
right now building this [ __ ] out
i'm not telling him chrissy d either
the first kid that greeted me i was like
he looks kind of young and this guy's
got on [ __ ] pampers
like what do you have here a chocolate
factory who's running this [ __ ]
hello is the grilli creeper growing
um dude he is how old are you man again
22.
22. 22. he's american dude yeah tell him
you're straight american aren't you i am
yeah i never said he wasn't american
there you go he was a boy
but look i know there's racial
connotation to everything
okay that's what people see yeah
he's um he's a good guy man good guy
riley mao an adult right riley i am and
where do you work at riley
in uh in nashville there you go
all right there you go let me ask you
this though this is pretty rehearsable
you guys been working on it in case the
cops come
i don't know what his [ __ ] problem is
where do you work at regularly riley
what does theo do after 10 30.
what's his favorite snack no i let him
run around on my back for a few minutes
i think theo likes cheerios
um here's what i'm asking you bro
dude your mic is looking for you bro
it's just getting further
the other day you might put up a wanted
poster to visit you
on it have you seen
it's just you with a picture of your
hand somebody gotta prank me where they
just like cement it in i go to push it
away
it's the new shake weight
he did 212 mics today hope you enjoyed
that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one